Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
J’aurais voulu vous parler de Georges,
de Jeanne, de Suzanne,
de tous ceux qui étaient
de charmants petits bébés en 1925,
qui ont eu la trentaine dans les années 50
et qui se sont retrouvés confinés
en maison de retraite médicalisée en 2020.
Mais là, tout de suite,
je préfère vous parler d’Émile,
cet homme qui m’a enseigné
à quel point les vieux,
aussi dépendants
que certains puissent paraître,
peuvent être d'une ressource insoupçonnée.
Orphelin de père à 15 ans,
Émile était rentré comme
élève à l’essai à la SNCF
et terminer sa carrière comme chef de gare
avait été l’achèvement d’une vie active
où il avait pu mettre tous
ses proches à l’abri du besoin.
Lorsque nous nous rencontrons pour
la toute première fois, Émile a 88 ans.
Il s’installe alors
en établissement d’hébergement
pour personnes âgées dépendantes.
Autrement dit, un EHPAD.
Vous en avez probablement beaucoup
entendu parler ces derniers temps.
Et il s’y installe avec Huguette
avec qui il est marié depuis 65 ans.
Huguette perd la tête.
Émile, lui, est épuisé par leur quotidien
et par toutes les difficultés
d’être humain en fin de vie.
Ils ont besoin d'aide.
Les voilà installés devant moi qui
porte la casquette de psychologue.
Moi, Ariane, jeune professionnelle
à ce moment-là,
et déjà fascinée par ces êtres qui
vous racontent la vie et sa complexité,
et ce, parfois, malgré eux.
Avec Émile et sa famille, nous parlons
beaucoup de la démence d’Huguette
et de toute cette situation
qui les fragilise.
Et en parallèle à nos rencontres,
je propose à Émile
de participer à un atelier mémoire.
Quelque chose de très courant
en EHPAD, mais j’y reviendrai.
Il refuse.
À ce moment-là, son esprit est pris
par les soins quotidiens
et par les déambulations d’Huguette, qui
commence à confondre le jour et la nuit.
Et puis les mois passent,
et une nuit d’hiver,
veillée par Émile, Huguette nous quitte.
Et pendant ce temps-là, de mon côté,
je suis en train de donner
la vie à mon premier enfant.
Par la suite, les semaines s’enchaînent,
et je retrouve Émile
qui me fait la surprise
d’avoir intégré l’atelier mémoire
de ma formidable collègue
psychomotricienne Lisa.
Jusque-là en retrait, il devient une
figure incontournable de l’établissement
alors que quelques semaines plus tôt, il
portait le deuil et le chagrin en fardeau.
Et puis, cet atelier s'arrête.
Une petite parenthèse.
Il faut savoir qu’un atelier mémoire
a pour ambition
de maintenir les capacités intellectuelles
de ses participants.
À travers des exercices,
nous cherchons à stimuler la mémoire,
le langage, la capacité à reconnaître
les gens et les choses autour de nous,
mais aussi les capacités à planifier des
gestes, des actes de la vie quotidienne,
bref, toutes ces capacités
qui nous permettent de jouir de la vie
de manière libre et indépendante.
Mais soyons honnêtes.
Si à la description de ce dispositif,
vous avez trouvé ça...
un petit peu pompeux,
je ne peux qu’être d’accord avec vous.
Pourquoi ?
Parce que tout ceci est très artificiel.
Pour que le vieillard reste
alerte et connecté à la vie,
on construit l’ambiance
dont il ne bénéficie plus,
c’est-à-dire un espace
adapté à ses capacités,
où les relations
et les activités sociales,
sources de plaisir et de satisfaction,
redonneraient du goût et du sens à sa vie.
Avec Lisa, nous avons vite compris
que ce n’était pas seules
que nous assumerions la lourde tâche
d’améliorer l’état émotionnel
et les capacités de nos participants.
Alors, nous avons proposé
tout autre chose :
la création d’un comité
de rédaction d’un magazine
qui embarquerait tous les acteurs
de l’établissement
et qui porterait les voix,
les expériences et les histoires
des personnes âgées dépendantes.
Tout ceci pour venir soutenir
leur devoir de transmission,
l’une des raisons pour lesquelles
elles sont toujours ici parmi nous.
Mais à l’heure du numérique,
où les jeunes générations trouvent
des réponses à leurs questions en un clic,
Émile a aussitôt pris peur.
« Mais qui va nous lire ? » nous a-t-il
lancé quand on a présenté le projet.
Qui va nous lire ?
Qu’est-ce qu’on va bien pouvoir raconter ?
Et surtout, pour quoi faire ?
Autant de questions pour lesquelles
on n’avait que la théorie en réponse.
Et comme nos potentiels participants,
nous n’étions pas très confiantes tant ce
chemin était peu éclairé et peu intuitif.
Mais fidèles à ce que
nous ressentions pour eux,
c’est-à-dire une curiosité
et un intérêt infinis,
nous étions persuadées
que si leurs récits nous intéressaient,
nous, jeunes gens des années 2020,
alors d’autres le seraient aussi.
Nous leur avons demandé
d’écrire quand ils le pouvaient
ou de parler lorsque
leurs mains les lâchaient.
Toujours en groupe pour se sentir
portés et toujours encouragés.
Chaque semaine, à la même heure,
nous n’avons cessé de revisiter le siècle
passé avec nos histoires personnelles
pour enrichir ce magazine.
Souvenirs de l’Occupation, des jeux
d’enfance, de l’école, des vacances,
un tas de sujets nous ont réunis,
alors qu’à notre naissance,
rien ne nous destinait à nous rencontrer.
Certains pouvaient se repérer
dans le temps et dans l’espace.
D’autres en revanche avaient besoin
de nos repères pour ne plus rester coincés
dans la case « démence sénile »
qui empêche de réaliser
des choses marquantes et positives.
Et puis, les années ont passé
et un écosystème s’est créé.
Un écosystème où la personne âgée
dépendante était au centre de l’univers,
à nouveau capable de tout.
Un réseau d’aide s’est naturellement
construit avec des soignants
accompagnant les résidents à l’atelier,
avec des salariés
jouant le jeu de l’écriture,
avec des familles prêtes à retrouver
des objets oubliés dans les greniers,
à écrire, prendre des photos, dessiner.
Et sans que nous ayons pu l’imaginer,
le magazine est devenu un sujet de
discussion lors des rencontres familiales.
Des petits-enfants -
d’ailleurs, ils sont déjà adultes -
nous ont confié avoir appris des choses
sur leurs grands-parents
en lisant le magazine.
Émile est venu à chaque rencontre
Écrire, il ne l’avait jamais fait ;
et d’ailleurs, il n’y arrivait plus.
Mais peu importe,
il venait avec des articles
dont il avait surligné les passages
et dont il voulait qu’on fasse un papier.
Il venait avec des objets
qu’il avait gardés précieusement
pour illustrer ses propos.
Sa grande fierté,
un sifflet comme celui-ci,
avec lequel, un jour, il nous a tous
surpris pour qu’on se taise,
pour qu’on s’assoie et qu’on célèbre la
parution du magazine autour d’un cocktail.
Ce sifflet, c’était un cheminot
en départ à la retraite
qui lui avait offert
quand il avait 15 ans.
C’était un vieux, très vieux sifflet.
Il faut dire qu’Émile était loin
d’être le seul à nous surprendre.
Dans le comité de rédaction,
il y avait Augustine,
totalement perdue dans le temps,
qui revenait à chaque rencontre
en ayant oublié ce qu’on avait
abordé la fois précédente.
Pas très pratique,
mais notre bienveillance sans jugement
lui permettait de se raccrocher aux wagons
et de donner le meilleur qu’elle pouvait :
raconter son enfance dans le bassin
minier du nord de la France.
Elle était la seule, mais surtout
la meilleure, pour le faire.
Avec elle, nous avons redécouvert
une partie de l’histoire
à travers les yeux d’une enfant amusée
et pas du tout effrayée
par les défilés chantants des Allemands.
Et puis, il y avait Gustave qui
était incollable sur la cosmologie.
Gustave, qui ne pouvait aller nulle part
sans son déambulateur
et sans risquer de chuter.
Vous savez, Gustave,
il avait ce pas de sénateur.
Tous ses gestes et tout son corps
étaient empêtrés dans la lenteur.
Mais Gustave, il s'est révélé être capable
de parcourir tout l'établissement
pour se rendre à nos réunions,
même s’il mettait 45 minutes
pour le faire.
Et même si sa tête le conduisait
à se présenter en salle de travail...
nos jours de repos.
Comme le rappelle Boris Cyrulnik,
empêchaient le récit d’un âgé, c’est lui
interdire la seule action qui lui reste.
C’est l’empêcher de prendre sa place.
C’est l’exclure, c’est l’isoler
socialement, affectivement,
c’est le rendre confus et désorienté.
Ce magazine, c’était un espace
de rencontre culturelle et générationnelle
où l’étoile du berger était
la transmission.
Écrire, raconter, faire le récit de soi
dans un magazine
qui traverserait le temps,
c’était léguer une partie
de notre histoire
là où nos modes de vie
ne nous offrent plus le temps,
ni l’espace pour faire
se rencontrer des générations.
Qu’avons-nous appris
de toute cette aventure ?
Nous avons appris que derrière
le parkinsonien dément et désorienté,
il y avait l’ancien ingénieur capable
de retrouver sa pensée logique
pour nous raconter la naissance des NTIC.
Nous avons appris que
derrière l’homme qui n’écrit plus
et dont les mains
sont rongées par l’arthrose,
il y avait l’ancien jeune homme
capable de nous enseigner la pâtisserie
en oubliant sa douleur
et son déambulateur.
Nous avons appris que derrière l’homme,
tantôt heureux, tantôt colérique,
il y avait l'ancien SDF et alcoolique.
Ce même homme qui nous a enseigné
à quel point les réalités familiales
peuvent être diverses
et conduire à des ruptures
extrêmement douloureuses.
Ce même homme que nous avons vu d’une
patience et d’une bienveillance infinies
à l’égard de ses compagnons désorientés
[nous a appris] que notre passé
ne nous définit pas toujours
et que de nouveaux liens
sont possibles à tout âge.
Qu’avons-nous appris
de toute cette aventure ?
Nous avons appris à arrêter de voir
la personne âgée dépendante
sous le prisme de l’obsolescence,
mais de voir cachés derrière elle
l’enfant et l’adulte qu’elle a été
et qui l’ont conduite jusqu’à nous,
dépendante et affaiblie.
Nous avons appris que derrière les êtres
humains plaintifs et dépressifs,
il pouvait y avoir eu des violences
ordinaires répétées
ou des maltraitances extraordinaires
et nous avons pris
conscience de leur force destructrice.
Nous avons appris que,
tout comme l’être qu’on dit atypique,
le vieux dépendant était trop souvent
incompris dans ses besoins fondamentaux
et qu’en comblant ses besoins
avec respect et bienveillance,
les affres de la différence
pouvaient être vécues plus sereinement.
Émile est décédé après avoir participé
à quatre numéros du magazine.
Enceinte pour une deuxième fois
et accompagnée de mes collègues,
nous sommes allés à son enterrement
et c’est à son petit-fils
qu’est revenu l’honneur
de donner un dernier coup de sifflet
pour annoncer le départ du train d’Émile.
Tout au long de cette rencontre,
je vous ai emmenés avec moi
dans le passé et dans les souvenirs,
dans les chemins tortueux que peuvent
prendre certaines de nos existences.
Faisons maintenant un bond
dans le présent,
dans cette actualité si brutale.
Printemps 2020 : la moitié
de l’humanité est confinée.
Et d’ailleurs, il nous aura fallu
peu de temps pour comprendre
que le confinement avait pu
avoir des effets dramatiques
sur les personnes les plus vulnérables.
Nos aînés dans les EHPAD se sont vu
imposer « la peste ou le choléra » :
mourir d’une pandémie historique ou
mourir confiné de chagrin et de solitude.
Car mesdames et messieurs,
si on peut bien s’imaginer ce que c’est de
mourir d’une maladie respiratoire aiguë,
mourir de chagrin
n’est pas juste une image,
c’est une réalité déchirante.
Et pas besoin d’une pandémie pour faire
perdre à nos vieux le goût de vivre.
Tous les jours, année après année,
nous ne cessons de constater
à quel point la condition du vieux
a été gangrenée par la culture
d’une poignée de dominants.
Une culture qui valorise les rapports
de force, l’exclusion des vulnérables,
la normalisation de la violence et qui
craint par-dessus tout ce qu’elle appelle
la dépendance, la vulnérabilité
et la mort.
Ce magazine s’est développé
en puisant dans une synergie.
D’une part, nous avons redonné
une classe sociale à l’ancien
et le plaisir que cela a suscité
nous a illustré
à quel point ceci le soigne et l’apaise.
D’autre part, nous, les professionnels,
les familles, les lecteurs -
et vous aussi peut-être -
nous avons reçu une leçon d’humilité
que les livres et Internet
ne nous offriront jamais.
Ce magazine est venu nous rappeler
à quel point
les personnes les plus avancées
en âge ont des histoires
auxquelles nous ne prêtons
plus suffisamment attention,
des histoires qui viennent nous
éclairer une diversité de chemins,
à prendre ou à éviter,
notamment quand nous,
dernière génération,
sommes en proie au doute
et aux difficultés.
Il y en aura peut-être parmi vous
qui ont un proche installé en EHPAD
et pour qui tout ceci
suscitera beaucoup d’émotion.
Si le cœur vous en dit,
allez donc lui rendre une petite visite,
je suis certaine que ça fera plaisir
à tout le monde.
Mais si ce n’est pas le cas,
non, je ne vous encourage pas à aller
faire un câlin à cette grand-mère
que la démence n’aura jamais rendue
aussi blessante et humiliante.
Non, je ne vous encourage pas non plus
à vous réconcilier avec ce père
qui vous a abusé durant l’enfance.
Et je ne souhaite pas non plus vous
exposer à vos angoisses les plus intimes
face à l'impuissance qu'impose
la dépendance d'un proche.
Nous faisons tout ce que nous pouvons,
avec ce que nous avons.
Je vous en supplie, respectez-vous.
Néanmoins, si on croit que tout est foutu
pour notre proche devenu dépendant,
on peut apprendre qu'il y a des moyens
pour maintenir le lien avec lui.
Derrière les murs des EHPAD diabolisés,
des professionnels construisent des outils
pour lutter contre
les effets néfastes de la dépendance.
Ces personnes-là
sont des alliés pour faire face à ce
qui dépasse le reste de la société.
Maintenant, pensez à vous.
Pensez à ce vieux en devenir qui rêve
légitimement d’une vieillesse sans séisme.
Vous pouvez dès à présent changer
vos représentations de la personne âgée.
Par exemple,
plutôt que de s’agacer derrière la vieille
dame un peu trop lente à la caisse,
pourquoi ne pas décider
de voir cette femme
qui va aussi vite
que ses capacités le lui permettent ?
Ou par exemple,
plutôt que de faire pétition
contre cette vieille voisine aigrie
qui s’attache un petit
peu trop à ses chats,
pourquoi ne pas décider
de rencontrer cette femme pour qui
les relations humaines sont devenues
trop complexes pour être réconfortantes ?
Car à force de voir le vieux
comme un gêneur,
nous l’inscrivons dans cette trajectoire
qui nous conduira tous
vers le drame de l’exclusion.
Petit à petit, nous pouvons changer
nos modes de vie
grâce aux sciences et à l’éthique du care.
Nous savons à quel point il peut
être important de faire évoluer
nos modes d’éducation
pour préserver nos enfants
de malheurs induits par nos comportements.
Nous pouvons prendre soin des relations
que nous entretenons
avec les gens que nous aimons.
Et quand nous ne pouvons plus
réparer ce qui a été brisé,
alors nous pouvons chercher
et privilégier toutes ces relations
qui nous donnent confiance
en nos capacités
et qui, surtout, excluent
l’emprise, la peur et l’humiliation.
Pourquoi est-ce que j’insiste tant
sur la qualité de nos relations ?
Car les relations que nous
entretenons les uns avec les autres
sont toutes autant de refuges
que nous trouverons
lors des moments difficiles
que la vie nous impose.
Et plus ce maillage de relations
est fort, solide et authentique,
plus nous nous promettons
la meilleure trajectoire possible
pour le reste de notre vie.
Mais si jamais vous prenez peur
face à cette recette
d’une vieillesse un peu plus sereine,
j’aimerais que vous preniez
conscience d’une chose :
que pour nous qui sommes en mesure
de nous rencontrer ici et maintenant,
dans cet espace-temps,
notre champ des possibles
est grand ouvert.
Et pour cela, je vous offrirais
cette pensée
qui me vient
de mes vieux collègues rédacteurs :
« Rien n’est jamais joué tant qu’on vit.
Face à chaque obstacle,
un autre chemin est toujours possible. »
Merci.
(Applaudissements)